hey this is Moshe kasher and it's Hacha
Leggero we just got married six months
ago which we think pretty much makes
those qualified to give love advice to
strangers so that's what we did we
packed up the car hit the road spread
the love yes - is there something that
you would like to discuss with the group
that you would like to maybe address in
your relationship with Josh but stuff
you want it or he wants it if you want
it he will be the luckiest man in the
world because I've never heard of that
I'm gonna give it what I'm gonna give it
Oh
okay that's so weird that's so weird
that Josh didn't want to come up
he's like I know I'm not getting picked
I'm not interested in getting paid if
you want that you find another guy told
you many many times on my leadership oh
that's so cool that she wants to do that
wait I don't think it's cool
what are you doing no please bought into
it my bola what sparked your interest in
the events inspirations this is clearly
something you brought up with him more
than once
oh why not oh I would say your partner
not consenting is a good reason know
what today is uh hump day why do people
still say it sorry month anniversary
hump day no today oh that's hump day
that's hump night because I'm a nut
month anniversary we need to hub okay
that's cool our wedding was fun was the
best best it was the first non-boring
wedding I've been to except for the
wedding of all of my friends and family
wish we could do it again we can do it
again we're going to Las Vegas tomorrow
we could straight-up do a wedding there
you want to renew our vows I guess we
would have to renew our vows yeah would
you really do that why not I think
that'd be fun we renew our vows and we
could go out on the town in Vegas baby
Vegas Vegas baby maybe like shooing what
is it about it is it what is it detect
as a psychological dynamic is it what's
the physical yeah yeah yeah it feels
dominating from a woman and that maybe
it's an ignorant part of my like little
like pathetic male brain but I don't
like the psychic the psychological
dynamics of it if I'm getting
emasculated I'm getting bent over in
you don't say
there's a pin a pencil but I'm just for
women
yeah
bitch
I haven't thought about our wedding
night a long time
all right let's go renew our vows then
you sure you want to renew your vows
with somebody that goes shoeing
well we never even had vows so I this
low risk ooh
so who should we have do the ceremony um
like a Liberace impersonator oh honey
I've a live brought you a person who
hasn't gotten a call in a long time ha
ha what about uh what about like a good
what uh Elvis no that seems cliché not
carrot-top impersonator
the care type impersonator and I just
carrot-top I mean that's a good point so
what if she just what if he just lets
her do it once and then if he doesn't
like it they never talk about it again
would you be happy with that Christine
yeah that's cool what if he was in to
say like um oh all you want to is put a
finger in there Josh man up dude
first of all you should clip your nails
I mean that's like the number one thing
I wouldn't want that on my ass about she
cuts her nails he lets her do it once
all the way okay and then never talk
although we got all the way all the
elbow what's the thing that you want the
relationship to you wish was different
nothing she does bothers you
except for trying to sexually assault
you every single night no we've got an
agreement keep the Kardashians out of
the house and we're good
oh so she can't watch reality TV type of
stuff so she's giving you that give her
one pinky okay how about one knuckle
yeah he says I'm right all right that
was good it was really good that was a
great show tonight oh the show yeah that
was good too you know I feel like we
really helped people with the love
advice for sure especially that one
couple oh the butt couple yeah I really
felt like we opened them up I agree all
right good night gonna happen good night
good night
do you have a problem with your love
life that you actually need help with or
do you just want to say hi my love life
yeah but I probably should be cool okay
cool thank you for coming appreciate it